immigration it's a scary word and
scarier when I say it like this
immigration but Lebs want to take anyone
in you're tired your poor your huddled
masses it's completely unamerican
luckily General John Kelly Trump's chief
of staff gets it the vast majority of
the people that move illegally into the
United States are not bad people they're
not criminals not ms-13 but they are
also not people that would easily
assimilate into the United States
they're overwhelmingly rural people in
the countries that come from 4th 5th 6th
grade education they're kind of the norm
yeah yeah immigrants need to be educated
skilled workers who know English have a
rockin bod ok he didn't say the last one
but I think it was implied but of course
the lives were ready to jump on Kelly's
so-called hypocrisy look general Kelly's
own family from the Brighton section of
Boston his father was Irish his mother
was Italian his great-grandfather was a
wagon driver who was reportedly
illiterate Italian didn't speak English
his maternal grandmother had a fruit
cart see John Kelly's ancestors were
exactly the kind of high achievers he
wants an America in those days wagon
driver and fruit peddler were basically
CEO an iPhone invented
the point is back then immigrants had
merit and here to agree with me is
citizen journalist Kobi levy no Kobe
Kobe you are an expert in history
correct Jordan I'm histrionic and John
Kelly's right America has a
long-standing immigration policy called
no scrubs we only let in highly skilled
people the first Thanksgiving was
actually just the pilgrims partying
after they finished their PhD
dissertations well help those Native
Americans must have learned so much from
them about farming corn and not freezing
in winter big-time and the Irish who
came over during the potato famine were
all doctors in there careful study of
nutrition and the human body they
discovered that not eating is bad for
you well incredible research now groups
this well-educated must have been
immediately accepted into American life
absolutely that's why you'll never hear
a mean joke about a Polish person and
never heard one so these immigrants had
something to offer and achieve the
American dream without a doubt because
the American dream is coming over with
established wealth and a marketable
trade and then pretty much staying
exactly where you are otherwise you're a
scrub and you can't get no love from me
you think America is exclusive we're
like the Harvard of countries there's a
quota on Asians well yes but also
not everyone can get in you might get
wait-listed or you might have to go to
your safety country which funnily enough
for asylum seekers is much less safe so
if you want to get out of a war zone and
get into America first you just need to
get a masters from your war zone
University in math or science or the
politics of surviving a genocide and
then you can immigrate to America once
you have skills real skills valuables
not too many skills though Jordan then
they'll take our jobs so okay so okay so
we want just the right level of skills
not too many not too few like Goldilocks
okay now that's that's an immigrant I
can get behind cute sweet hates nature
and something about her blonde hair just
fits with my idea of America well that's
the ultimate skill Jordan looking like
you fit in just ask John Kelly's
great-grandparents but make sure you do
it in Italian because I don't speak a
word of English yes thanks Kobe the
fight continues
[Music]